and this logic of transgenderism is
leading to something that is
really to my mind absolutely disgusting
this is leading to calls among prominent
senate democrats
to force women to register for the draft
this story is not getting a lot of
coverage politico did
did just report on it though
senate democrats are proposing a
sweeping rewrite of the military draft
laws
to require women to register for the
selective service system
according to a draft a draft of the
report authored by senate armed services
chairman
jack reed which was obtained by politico
this would be attached to the national
defense authorization act a defense
policy bill that is one of the few
pieces
that is considered a must-pass by
congress so they're going to try to ram
it in
to some legislation that congress is
just going to have to pass
so that they can get this through
i do not want to live in a country that
requires women to fight our wars for us
i don't want to live in that country
it's just wrong now
i see how we got to this point
a lot of people are going to say well
this is just too far or this is crazy or
this is but
no this is the logic of the last 50
years
the logic of second wave feminism or i'm
sorry the premise of second wave
feminism
is that women and men are basically the
same sure they look a little different
but hey a woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle as gloria steinem said
the differences between men and women
are purely superficial women can do
anything men can do
and how dare you say otherwise well okay
if that's true if men and women are
basically
exactly the same then
surely the homosexual rights movement as
it was once called
is gonna go through no well of course
because men and women are exactly the
same
surely the redefinition of marriage
which was
the apotheosis of that movement has to
go through because men and women are
exactly the same so if
if men and women are the same then your
argument
that marriage is the union between one
man and one woman falls apart
these men and women are the same so then
i guess it could be the union of one man
and one man or one woman and one woman
and if that's true then the logic of
transgenderism has to hold
because if men and women are basically
the same then bruce jenner certainly can
become caitlyn
because those differences are just
superficial get a little nip tuck here
throw on some stilettos and a little bit
of lipstick and there you have it
bruce is caitlin and frankly
he didn't even need to do that he could
have just said he's a woman as
as many people do now and that would
have been perfectly fine
and if men and women are exactly the
same then of course
women need to register for the draft
it would be unfair it would be unjust if
only men registered for selective
service and the problem with all of that
is
it's all false it's based on a false
premise
men and women are different this is the
fundamental distinction in human nature
men and women are not identical they are
complementary
they go together like love and marriage
like horse and carriage
you can't have one without the other in
in society
so you're going to hear two arguments on
this
from the right you're going to hear
i'm just talking about people who oppose
women
registering for the draft you're going
to hear two kinds of arguments
one is the egghead arguments they're
going to tell you well actually you know
if you look at certain statistics and if
you look at um the levels of
testosterone and the way that the
uh and the bones and the this and the
development then actually women
are not quite suited for the draft and
blah blah blah
fine you know i'm willing to take any
argument that persuades anybody but that
to me is not the real argument
i don't even care if some other egghead
on the other side could prove that women
actually
do have the same bone density and the
same kind of muscle mass and actually
they're just as competent in the field
and that
i don't care i don't want to live in
that country going back to the edmund
burke quote
when he lamented during the french
revolution that the age of chivalry is
gone
and that of sophisters economists and
calculators has succeeded at the glory
of europe is extinguished forever
i don't want to live in the world of
sophistre's economists and calculators
i don't care if you can prove to me that
by measuring testosterone and bone
density or any other physical feature
that men and women are very very similar
men and women are different and
a country that sends its women to fight
its wars is an
ugly unchivalrous uncivilized country
i want to live in a country where men go
fight the wars to protect the women
where we have a real complementary
complementarity of the sexes
where we actually work together and care
for one another and we don't just all
pretend
that we're all exactly the same i'm glad
you like that clip
i want you to watch the whole show the
title of which is the bill comes
due check it out on apple pocket spotify
stitcher google play
here on youtube ring the bell like
subscribe
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you